-My first guest is the
creator and star of
the Emmy-winning animated series
"Big Mouth."
He's one of my
all-time favorites.
It premieres its fourth season
this Friday on Netflix.
Here is Nick Kroll.
There -- Look at this. Wow!
Oh, you're waving.
-Hi.
-Let me -- You're waving
with the wrong --
No, wave with the other --
Stop.
-Is this it?
-Slower.
-No, other hand.
Is that a ring?
-Is this the framing?
-Is that the ring?
-Oh, this is a ring.
-Nick Kroll,
you got married, buddy.
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
-I got married.
Can you see it?
-Yes. It's beautiful.
-I've turned off self view
on Zoom
so not to look at myself
the entire interview.
-Oh, interesting.
-I got married.
Yeah.
-That's amazing, buddy.
From the photo that you
posted on Instagram --
Look at that.
Are you kidding me?
That is a gorgeous setting
for a wedding.
Where even is that?
-We were on a cliff in
California, in Big Sur.
And it was
really, really beautiful.
And it was just us.
It was really --
It was pretty magical.
It was pretty beautiful.
-That's great.
-Yeah.
-Do you mind me asking,
how was the proposal?
Were you nervous?
Did you talk it out
ahead of time?
Did you plan it out?
Was it a bit? Was it funny?
-It was -- No, you know,
we've been in --
I don't know if
you know this, Jimmy,
but we've been in
this global pandemic.
I don't know if you're
aware of it, but --
Yeah, write it down.
"Global pandemic."
-Is that L-E? Global?
-Yes, global. Yes.
And so I haven't
really seen many people.
Like, we're all just
kind of in our homes
and doing our very small lives.
And so I've been
largely with my fiancée,
and then so I had --
At the time, we were dating.
I wasn't sure
how to propose to her.
I couldn't talk to her about it.
-Yeah.
-So, I had just started working
on this movie called
"Don't Worry Darling"
that Olivia Wilde is directing.
-Oh, yeah.
-And it's starring
Harry Styles and Florence Pugh
and a really great cast.
-Oh, yeah,
I know about this, yeah.
-And, so, we -- I was, like,
at the table read with them,
and we -- I knew
I wanted to propose
and I hadn't really been able to
talk to anybody about like,
"How do I do this?"
So, I sort of ran through
some ideas with them and --
-With Florence and Harry Styles?
-Yeah, yeah.
I was like -- I was just,
you know, spit-balling
with "Flo" and "H-Bomb,"
and, you know, my --
And, so, we -- And Olivia.
And we were all just sort of
chatting about it,
and I came up with
an idea that I liked,
which was to -- Like, we had
just moved into a new house.
And, so, I -- We were moving,
and so I put a huge bouquet of
flowers into a moving box
and then the ring at the center
of the flowers.
And my now-wife was, like,
moving stuff in the closet,
and I was like, "Hey, Lily,
can you come in here
and move this --
Can you open this one box?"
And she was like,
"I'm in the closet --"
you know, like,
just annoyed, moving,
like, "What do you --
Just let me..."
And then she came out and
opened the box and saw the ring
and the flowers and, you know,
was very surprised.
And, you know, she said yes.
-Aww! That's great.
-And we were, like,
getting ready to, like,
call our parents
and, you know, like,
take a picture
and all that stuff,
and Harry Styles texted me to be
like, "Have you done it yet?
Like, what's going on?"
-Dude, he's the best dude ever.
-And I was like -- Yeah.
And I was like,
"Yes. She said yes."
And, so, Harry Styles was
the first person
to know that we were
getting married.
Like, before my parents,
before Lily's parents,
before anybody,
like, Harry was
the first person to know.
And he gave us his blessing,
and it meant the world.
-Is that -- That is perfect.
He is such a classy dude.
-He really is.
And then we got -- When we got
married in Big Sur,
he sent us a huge bouquet
of flowers.
And, like, just so lovely
and kind,
and he doesn't know this yet,
but he is now going to be
the guardian
of all of our children.
-Oh, my God.
I don't know if
he agreed to that.
That's unbelievable.
H-Bomb himself.
-The man.
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
"Big Mouth," Season 4.
This is everyone's
favorite show.
Everyone loves it.
They're like,
"Did you see 'Big Mouth'?"
I go, "Yeah, I've seen it.
Yeah, he's been on the show.
Yeah, we know him."
Season 4 coming to Netflix
this Friday.
It takes place at a summer camp,
which I've never been to.
You went to summer camp
as a kid?
-Yes, I went to --
So, summer camp, a lot of --
I went to summer camp
growing up in Maine,
this camp called Wildwood,
and Andrew Goldberg,
who I created "Big Mouth" with,
alongside Mark Levin
and Jennifer Flackett --
he and I grew up together,
and we went to summer camp
together as kids.
And so we pulled a lot of stuff
from that experience.
Like, we had a --
I had a camp best friend,
and when Andrew
came to join me at camp,
they became best friends.
And so we brought in
a new character.
Seth Rogen is our camp --
my camp best friend,
and his name is Seth --
in the show is Seth Goldberg,
because I had Andrew Goldberg,
and Seth's writing and directing
partner is Evan Goldberg.
And Seth and I realized
that it's in the Bible that,
"Thou shalt not covet
thy neighbor's wife.
and "Thou shalt have a Goldberg
that one grows up with
and then writes
TV and movies with."
-That's correct. That's correct.
-It's a rich part
of the Jewish tradition.
-I want to show a clip,
everyone.
Here's a look at Season 4
of "Big Mouth,"
out this Friday on Netflix.
Check it out.
-I'm freaking out.
-[ Echoing ]
Are you having a panic attack?
-What? Who said that?
-Me! I did.
-Aah! What the hell are you?!
-I'm Tito, the anxiety mosquito.
-Anxiety mosquito?
Ow!
-I'm sorry.
People hate it when I do that.
People hate it
when I do everything.
But do I stop?
-Ugh!
-You killed me.
I get it. I'm the worst.
But so are you.
-I know. Andrew hates me.
-And so does Seth.
They're probably making fun
of you right now.
-You think so?
-Here's what
they're definitely saying.
"Nick is a whiny little baby."
"Let's jerk off on his pillow."
[ Laughs ]
-No! Please stop
saying this stuff.
-You're going to have
the worst summer.
Everyone's going to hate you.
-Nick and I are playing
"Guess the Impression"
when we come back.
Come on back, everybody.